enemies to the east
enemies to the south and arya's sand and
her brood of [ __ ]
enemies to the west
oh lena the old [ __ ] another traitor
enemies to the north
ned stark's bastard has been named king
in the north and that murdering [ __ ]
sansa stands beside him
enemies everywhere were surrounded by
traitors hey guys cersei has enemies all
around her she is basically surrounded
and while it seems like the mad's
queen's reign will not last long i think
we should reconsider that while cersei
is ruthless and ambitious in the
upcoming episodes she might prove to all
of us that she is also a master
strategist as she believes she is
however cersei needs to make new
alliances since she almost completely
destroyed the only lannister's strong
ally with wildfire in the season 6
finale and therefore lost their support
but the most powerful ally of cersei
will without a doubt be euron greyjoy
about which i'm going to talk in details
in my upcoming videos cersei still needs
more allies and most importantly cersei
needs an ally that would ensure the
provision of a foe to the capital which
is of the great importance in the time
of war winter's here
we can't win a war if we can't feed our
men and our horses as jaime pointed out
even the lannisters can't survive
without allies since not only that they
lack of military strength but they also
lack of food to feed their own men and
horses the new queen of the seven
kingdoms has only two possibilities she
has to either make an alliance with a
powerful house of the most fertile part
of westeros which would be a powerful
house of the reach or she could try to
negotiate a new deal with the iron bank
or bravos and try to persuade bank into
funding divorce none of those seem
possible since the reach is ruled by
house terrell one of the biggest enemies
of house lannister and the iron bank on
the other hand certainly will not
support cersei neither as they lost
their fate in the lane is serves upon
tywin's death
additionally upon noticing that the
crown is not and will not be able to
repay its debt the iron bank of bravos
will decide to as they usually do
support and fund the enemy of the
current ruler in order to destroy the
one that owes the money in this case
cersei lannister and in order to get
their money back the iron bank most
certainly will not fund cersei's wars
but will rather fund one of her enemies
whom they see as a king or a queen
capable of being successful in the long
run however while it seems like cersei
is doomed we might be wrong as the
season premiere actually gave us a few
strong hints regarding cersei's new
allies that would provide her both an
army and the provision of a foe to the
capital
the tyrells have the grain the tyrells
have the livestock
will the tyrell bannermen stand
alongside a dothraki horde and unsullied
slave soldiers jaime mentioning
much-needed terrell supplies and cersei
questioning the tyrell banners man's
loyalty might be foreshadowing a huge
betrayal of the most powerful vessel
house who sworn filthy to house terrell
a huge betrayal house starly over lady
elena tyrell i know that at first it
does sound extremely surprising as how
starley of horn hill is among the houses
that's fair filthy to house terrell of
highgarden but the fact is that the head
of house starly has always been loyal
towards lord paramount of the reach but
has always despised real women now that
all male tyrells are killed elena is
left as a sole member and ruler of house
tyrell accompanied with the fact that
randall tarly has always despised real
women this aligns between the lannisters
and the turtles after all is not that
surprising
even though randall fought on
targaryen's side during robert's
rebellion along with his liege lord mace
randall will once again declare for the
current ruler of the seven kingdoms but
will this time fight against house
targaryen as cersei said herself the
tyrell bannerman including the best
battlefield commander in all of the
seven kingdoms randall will not stand
alongside the tracky horde and unsolid
slave soldiers in addition beside
randall's betrayal in the season
premiere cersei also foreshadowed how
exactly she is going to persuade randall
into swearing filthy to her
we need allies
stronger better allies we can't win this
war alone
i think i listened to father for 40
years and learned nothing
even though this statement might not
seem to be of the great importance it
actually might be a foreshadow of a
cersei orchestrating complete fall of
house tyrell in the upcoming episodes
cersei's father tywin lannister
orchestrated the red wedding and as a
reward for their betrayal valder frey
was granted riverrun and protection
while rose bolton on the other hand was
appointed as the new warden of the north
as well as the new lord of winterfell in
my opinion there's a high possibility
that cersei's quote about learning from
her father might be a foreshadow that
cersei will just like timing persuade
the powerful vessel house into betrayal
over their sworn house by promising them
titles lands and castles for his
betrayal over elena tyrell randall will
most probably be awarded that place in
the small council and it's also easy to
assume that he would be appointed as the
new lord paramount of the reach and
warden of the south once they make an
alliance jaime lands her leading
lannister army along with randall and
dick and tarly leading their tarly army
will march on highgarden the seat of
house tyrell this march will result with
jaime's and randall's victory which is
not surprising since they will have
numbers they will outnumber terrell
soldiers and both of them have a lot of
military experience randall tarly in
particular who is known as one of the
best battle commanders in the seven
kingdoms
during robert's rebellion randall
commanded the royalists victory at the
battle of ashford the only defeat that
robert baratheon ever suffered in the
entire war which says for itself how
effective general randall truly is
however beside the most important
purpose besides destroying their enemy
and decreasing daenerys strength by
conquering highgarden cersei would also
conquer important crossroads as
highgarden lies on the banks of the
river mander and is where the ocean road
meets the rose road and is a major
passage linking old town and king's
landing beside those two facts
highgarden also has rich fields and was
provisioning food to the capital
something the lannisters lost with
killing almost every member of house
tyrell in the third season margery
perhaps even foreshadowed this assault
on highgarden there's a scene in which
margery reminded cersei of the
importance of house tyrell's support in
the war as the rich provided food to the
capital i'm glad house tyrell has been
able to help in this regard
they tell me a hundred wagons arrive
daily now from the reach wheat barley
apples we've had a blessed harvest and
of course it's our duty to assist the
capital in time of need
as i said earlier in this video cersei
has to and most likely will make
alliances with a powerful vessel house
of house terrell to overthrow lady elena
where upon that same vessel house would
become the great house and would rule
over the reach therefore cersei would
ensure the provision of a food to the
capital which is of the great importance
in the time of war however there is a
high possibility that beside conquering
the terrell's stronghold this march will
also resolve the death of the queen of
thorns with the fall of highgarden the
death of lady elena seems almost certain
and just like they are stated in the
leaked plot shortly before her death
lady elena will most likely admit to
jaime everything about how she and
littlefinger poisoned joffrey i know
that most of you are probably wondering
why would elena admit to jaime that she
killed his firstborn son but it's
actually pretty simple if you still
remember a conversation between lady
elena and peter baelish which happened
in the seventh episode of season five
the future of house tyrell don't pretend
to have any concern for my house my
grandchildren or me
i should have known you'd return to the
capitol as soon as things started to go
wrong i promise you i promise you lord
baelish that our fates are joined
together we murdered a king
if my house should fall i will have
nothing to hide
in this conversation the queen of thorns
threatened littlefinger and promised him
that if her house should fall she will
have nothing to hide meaning that if
house tyrell falls peter baelish will
follow along at the moment in the jaime
and randall are going to conquer
highgarden lady olenna will be aware
that her life is over that she can
either kill herself or become a hostage
which would also result with her death
eventually lady elena is well known for
her intellect and sarcasm which
accompanied with her intelligence and
her cunning skills resulted in her being
nicknamed the queen of thorns
lady elena aware that her fate is sealed
at the moment in which jaime is going to
confront her at highgarden she will
admit everything to jaime because as she
said herself she has nothing to hide
once her house falls while will will
surely miss the cunning lady elena
terrell i'm looking forward to see lil
fingers downfall as well as to finally
see a castle that is said to be among
the most beautiful castles in the seven
kingdoms highgarden perhaps cersei's
reign will not last that short as most
of us expected since it seems that the
madqueen will manage to persuade a few
powerful houses to pledge their armies
to her cause the first episode of the
seventh season is definitely the best
season premiere yet and while it all
left us speechless and most importantly
anxious in waiting for the second
episode i hope these predictions and
theories of mine will make the waiting
easier and as always let me know your
opinion about all of this in the comment
section down below